se trata de una reforma que podría
inclinar La balanza del poder en Israel
yarius levin ministro de Justicia del
nuevo gobierno de derecha israelí quiere
reducir fuertemente los poderes del
tribunal supremo con una cláusula de
anulación que permitiría la keneth
retrotraer una decisión del tribunal
supremo tras una votación el parlamento
estaría Entonces por encima del poder
judicial la falta de una constitución el
tribunal supremo israelí puede ahora
derogar las leyes que considere
contrarias a las leyes fundamentales del
país un poder demasiado importante para
el ministro de Justicia creo que no solo
la kenefet y el gobierno derivan su
poder de la confianza pública sino
también el poder judicial la revolución
judicial y el hecho de que el poder
judicial interfiera cada vez más en las
decisiones del gobierno y en las
votaciones de la keneth han hecho que la
confianza del público en el poder
judicial haya caído a mínimos históricos
esto debilita El poder del gobierno y
perjudica a la democracia la reforma
llega en un momento en que el Primer
Ministro Benjamín netanyahu está siendo
juzgado por corrupción los especialistas
seña que esta cláusula de anulación
permitiría al parlamento votar a favor
de la inmunidad judicial de netanyahu a
impediría al tribunal supremo revocar
esta decisión la reforma también
pretende revisar el método de
nombramiento de los magistrados del
tribunal supremo designados por un panel
de jueces diputados y abogados ahora se
reforzaría el peso de los cargos electos
en el proceso